the end of the year is upon us so we're
gonna be doing a little progress report
here I hope you guys had a chance to
check out my interview from last week
with Peter Bogosian for those of you
that might have missed it my intention
with Peter was to focus on atheism as
well as critical thinking these are
ideas that Peter wrote his book about
spends most of his time talking about
and are obviously topics that I'm
interested in I think at about 13
questions prepared for Peter but like
many of my interviews the conversation
pretty much just took a life of its own
and last week's case though something
particularly interesting happened no
matter how far I tried to steer the
conversation away from the regressive
left and I tried many times all roads
kept leading back to them I've mentioned
you guys a couple times now how I want
to talk about all kinds of things on
this show from science to politics to
spirituality and much more I've also
mentioned to you guys how I don't want
to solely focus on the regressive left
primarily because it doesn't necessarily
solve anything
still I find myself incredibly torn
about this topic on one hand until the
last couple months we hadn't even
diagnosed the problem of the regressive
left right clearly huge numbers of those
of you on the Left were upset about how
your team was being hijacked but there
wasn't a place to come together and talk
about it much less a whole group of
like-minded people willing to share
their experiences and tell their stories
for that reason I've wanted to keep this
conversation going it's important to
realize how many of us are actually out
there there are a lot we want to fix the
left but I don't think we can without
getting to critical mass on the issue on
the other hand I don't sense that we can
actually change these regresses as I've
also mentioned before since we've
started doing the show I've seen these
guys continue to lie and smear opponents
only to be caught and then double down
or even more some people are fighting
back against these lives with facts and
logic fortunately I've had several of
these people on the show like Maajid
Nawaz Cera hater and God said others I
know only from the online space such as
my guest this week ally Rizvi Ali's an
atheist Muslim who's constantly writing
about and fighting against regressive
ideology growing up mainly in Saudi
Arabia and ultimately leaving religion
for secularism
should be a natural hero of the left
sadly he's not that's one of the many
things that we're gonna talk about I go
back and forth between thinking that
fighting the regressives by putting time
and energy into discussing them is what
will ultimately do the most to change
the landscape of the left and then just
thinking that if we ignore them maybe
they'll go away I tend to think that
most of you will tell me that we have to
keep amplifying real liberal voices and
that by ignoring them we'll only let
their influence grow that's pretty much
what I think - I must say that I'm
incredibly inspired by the fact that
half the time when I see anything that
they write tweet or whatever there's an
army of people ready to combat their
[ __ ] a few people have mentioned to
me that they believe that this whole
regressive situation and the fuel that
it gives to the right is only gonna get
worse before it gets better
unfortunately I think these people are
probably correct until the real
legitimate true voices of liberalism can
come back to the forefront this
conversation is always going to be stuck
between the regressives and the Trump's
it looks like we've got our work cut out
for us for 2016